ja diese jahren böhmermann ist er
bereits in der sendung erwähnt worden
und ich hier im ärgere mich eigentlich
über nichts aber trotzdem habe ich das
einigermaßen entsetzt als ich dieses
gespräch zwischen böhmermann und markus
lanz da habe ich an einem zeit
gesprächsabend gesehen habe und da wirft
also dieses jahres gilt glaube ich auch
sagt er ich weiß auch nicht warum ich
das noch nie besonders lustig was er
machte nicht begreift diesen markus lanz
an von dem ich übrigens großen respekt
habe leider durch eine sendung auch
ideen noch echt eine diskussion
stattfindet nicht alle die gleiche
meinung vertreten rede und gegenrede
untersagt da stimmt doch tatsächlich
soll jetzt aufhören kritische virologen
einzuladen jan böhmermann strategie
irgendwann eine universität bis zu
seinem studienabschluss besucht sagt er
fertig mit dieser diskussion man so
nicht diese skeptiker einladen weil dann
frage ich mich an wlan kostet und dann
frage ich mich einfach nicht aus
beobachtet das ist ja eine art so der
star komiker deutschland so eine art
staat sorgt ihr ich hätte da eingesetzt
wird und den ist aber eigentlich ein
linker meinung sein student ist von oben
so zu sagen was ist der chef inquisitor
sagt was man denken was man zu halten
was man einladen darf und der ist im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk die
deutschen müssen für das zwangsgebühren
zahlen und da stimmt doch etwas mit dem
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk nicht
mehr wenn ein böhmermann dieser
satirischen in anführungszeichen diese
art von meinungs- schablonen vorgibt das
stimmt etwas mit dem öffentlich
rechtlichen aber stimmt auch etwas mit
dem humor nicht also diese dummen mann
scheint jedoch mit allem respekt eine
höchst fragwürdige figuren da jetzt die
deutschland da geht es ja nicht um humor
sondern da geht es um tabu zonen in der
öffentlichen diskussion und das ist ein
ding gewesen was er da vorgetragen hat
ja davon geredet dass markus lanz heißt
jetzt nicht aber gesagt hat tausende von
menschenleben dass da habe ich das spiel
hier vorgeworfen das hat ihm fern der
spiegel 90 euro gilt nach wie vor hoch
zwei menschenleben spielten einer
diskussion noch eine rolle er trägt das
vor und versucht das rechts links schema
auf die virologen zu übertragen es gibt
also linke virologen das sind herr
strikt der mal als laschet galt in
nordrhein-westfalen der als professor in
bonn und das ist herr kekulé das glaube
ich professor in hamburg messe halle
alle hatten die beiden die eine etwas
andere position vor den etwas liberaler
was die maßnahmen angeht gegen korona
etwas liberaler als andere biologen wenn
auf einmal als links hingestellt und wir
sind damit verboten und es dürfen nur
noch andere eingeladen werden das ist
natürlich eine art von anmaßung die man
von so einem menschen der nur für seinen
humor bezahlt wird in den sendungen
nicht ertragen kann das darf man auch
nicht gestattet werden wenn wenn wenn du
sagst moschee er hat sich aufgeschwungen
zudem großinquisitor und sensor er
versucht das es ist ihm nicht gelungen
ich glaube dass die bürger manchen
anmaßungen schon gescheitert sind also
den türkischen staatspräsidenten übel
beleidigt dass ich meine das will ich
jetzt langsam du kannst das sicher
besser beurteilen hier mit blick auf
deutschland als ich aber was ich
beunruhigend finde ist dass diese
böhmermann auf kosten des
gebührenzahlers unter dem deckmantel der
satire diese art neben von meinungs-
einpeitscher durchziehen kann und er hat
ja dann noch seine prätorianer garten in
den sozialen medien
man muss ja nicht alles lesen was die
scheinbar wenn du auch vom böhmermann
traum kommst dann hättest du dir gleich
noch seine bodentruppen auf den hans die
dann auf twitter facebook lampen sich
also allemal auskennt und so etwas wird
noch faktisch von steuergeldern
finanziert und das finde ich eigentlich
das skandalöse und böhmermann steht für
mich eben für eine tendenz im öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen toll finde ich
eben dieses bild live so gut finde ich
solche formate so gut weil die tod
wirklich lernen gehören blank verlängern
in den ganz engen unterhosen sind durch
die mittlerweile unterwegs beim
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen das
sind zum teil die diskussion ich gebe
ihnen recht in deutschland gibt es viel
meinungspluralität aber diese
meinungspluralität wird im öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen fernsehen immer
weniger abgebildet und das entspricht
nicht dem auftrag und böhmermann ist für
mich das sinnbild der auftrags
verfehlung des öffentlichen
verkehrs
eine sendung geben die runde sehr
leidenschaftlich nicht
es hat ja vor allem auch wenn sie fragen
nicht immer nur will das alte weise
männer zu wort kommen sondern das ist
auch ein meinungsführer
nichtig sei und damit komme ich jetzt
auch zur böhmermann ich hatte überhaupt
nicht das gefühl dass erkennt sehen will
sondern es geht ja tatsächlich darum das
wäre das mikro in der hand hat auch die
macht hat und dass das gesprochene wort
sage ich mal was eins zu eins auch im tv
übertragen wird auch als wahrheit
gedeutet wird und wenn da zum beispiel
jemand sitzt als wissenschaftler wo 99
prozent der aussagen wissenschaftlich
fundiert sind und man weiß dass das
sozusagen richtig ist und dann jemand
dagegen gesetzt wird einfach damit man
pro und contra hat mit nur einem prozent
können wir den zuschauern trotzdem ein
gleichgewicht von 50 zu 50 frachter ist
aber das ist nicht schlimm finde aber
ich sage ich auch aus also hatte nur zu
allen nett hambrecht in einem fall eine
art recht bei denen die wirtschaft lebt
davon dass wir immer wieder hinterfragen
und dass man jeden satz bereut sonst ist
es keine wissenschaft jedoch schon
alleine deshalb
wenn sie hält strikt als links
bezeichnen als linke aber dann will ich
ja gar nicht erst recht keine linke navi
rollo glaube ich nicht das hat er nie
gemacht dass eben als links bezeichnet
er die kritik nicht gesagt dass er links
ist so und da will ich noch mal gerne
zurück draufkommen dass das merkt zum
beispiel auch beim migrationsthemen die
sind immer problemorientiert und man
sucht immer die negativbeispiele und
dadurch entsteht natürlich ein
geschmäckle und trotzdem sage ich dass
wir uns das erlauben können zu
diskutieren deswegen bin ich heute hier
obwohl auch viele damit ein problem
haben ja also ich lasse mir da sozusagen
nicht einreden dass ich was nicht darf
und das ist ja das muss ich dieses land
so schätze dass wir tatsächlich machen
können was wir wollen was von der
meinungsfreiheit
aber wenn aber im mantel des der
meinungsfreiheit demagogie betrieben
wird
kann man dann kann man das nicht einfach
so stehen lassen und wieder ruhe
bewahren da muss man doch gegen
haltegriffen beziehungsweise muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich mich nicht
mit jedem mit einer runde stellen will
ich werde heute schon extrem
herausgefordert gebe ich auch zu das ist
gerade an der grenze aber zu machen da
auch die ganze scherz
aber ich sage mal so ich finde schon
dass ist bestimmte thesen gibt ich sage
es noch mal ganz konkret ja wenn man
dann zum beispiel sagt dass die juden an
einem schuld sind dann ist das für mich
keine meinungsfreiheit sondern dann ist
dass antisemitismus
punkten eine sekundarschule das wort dem
ist einfach ein bisschen der metapher
nach dass die im öffentlichen rundfunk
mit sehr engen unterhosen unterwegs das
muss ich aber nach der sendung noch mal
so heißt das aber dass sich meine
vorstellung ganz im ernst zimmermann hat
zwei dinge dort den raum gestellt einmal
hat er eine kultur des bühne bieten
beziehungsweise des
meinungsaustauschs stellt nun neige ich
nichts dazu dass ich meinungen irgendwie
toxisch finde und die zuschauende masse
da draußen für infizierte alte ich sehe
mir eigentlich den größten schwachsinn
an und wählen selbst aus was ich davon
für richtig also ich finds immer
schwierig wenn sich jemand sozusagen zum
torhüter der richtigen meinung auch
schwingt auch wenn ich selbst
schmerzgrenzen hätte also irgendwelche
einpeitscher die jetzt anfangen anhand
der kohlelieferungen irgendwie auschwitz
zu bezweifeln da wäre dann auch das
andere problem ist dass er für diese
these die man vertreten kann wenn man
das gerne möchte
ausgerechnet virologen heranzieht deren
leistung er nun beim besten willen nicht
einschätzen kann und er kommt dann
irgendwie ja die haben nicht publiziert
alexander kekulé ist eine der
langgedienten virologen überhaupt lange
jahre auch kolumnen im tagesspiegel
gespielt geschrieben
und es trägt ist nun wahrlich ein völlig
respektierter ehrenhafter virologe einer
einer ganz normalen universität und dann
kommt ein satiriker und wählt jetzt aus
zwischen wissenschaftlern die zulässig
sind in der öffentlichkeit und nicht
zulässig und dass er die hybris der da
liegt nicht selbst spürt ist eigentlich
ein interessantes krankheitsbild was man
mal irgendwie untersuchen sollte aber
erst konfrontiert wurden auch von herrn
land die sendung von herrn lanz ist ja
deswegen so beliebt weil er
meinungsvielfalt auf das gelände absolut
absolut und also auch in der
wissenschaft nicht getrübt leben von
nochmal jedem in seiner rede also ich
meine aristoteles hat über 1000 jahre
nicht widerlegt worden mit einer theorie
das ist ein großer stein schneller fällt
also ein kleiner stein whisky galileo
dann das experiment gemacht hat und das
nach
diesen punkt muss ich einsetzen ich
berufe mich immer noch sokratis ich weiß
dass ich nichts weiß und das stört mich
bei diesem böhmermann und das stört mich
zusehends beim öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk dort sind eben genau diese
torhüter die sagen ja nein diese den
virologen lassen wir nicht rein und ich
sage einfach als jemand der in der
demokratie aufgewachsen ist in
deutschland gearbeitet und gelebt hat
das tolle an einem land an einer
demokratie ist dass man eben offen
spricht und da redet manchmal vielleicht
eintracht den umsehen da haben sie
völlig recht dass muss man halt zu
lassen es gibt sich hier grenzen aber
die disqualifizieren sich selber aber
was ich hier beobachte und hier geht es
mir um den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk ist eben eine verengung und das
ist gefährlich denn in einer politik in
einer demokratie müssen sie immer die
meinungsvielfalt haben damit sie
überhaupt die übersicht über die
position haben und sie sind wir auch ein
bischen fast zum standard in der
torhüter richtung urlaub
mit meiner arbeit im reinen würde ich
bin bisher nur durch jana einen ganz
anderen aspekt hingegen glaube ich
glaube wir müssen immer man arbeite
jedoch
will man arbeitet nach dem prinzip von
regelmäßig große debatten zu provozieren
indem man sowas sagt indem er den
türkischen staatspräsidenten beleidigt
indem man den lanz angreift indem man
zwei virologen an es ist lange nicht
mehr über ihn diskutiert worden höchste
zeit dass es passiert und wir tun ihm
den gefallen
[Musik]